wer weiß schon freuen
jeder tag ist
er weiß schon heute morgen sind immer
und wieder alles neu begeht
das ist das erste deutsche fernsehen mit
der tagesschau jetzt sind wir da wo wir
sind glaube ich mitten ins zentrum was
ich mir ein bisschen größer vorgestellt
aber ich muss sagen sie schon recht
schön ist klein aber fein das ist schon
schön wollte mal wissen wo wir unsere
ganze inspiration für unsere musik da da
da unser großes vorbild unser idol
betroffen
okay wir befinden uns in bonn der
ehemaligen hauptstadt in deutschland
schön ist sie das wetter nicht so hinter
uns ist die münsterkirche schicken wir
ein bisschen durch bonn
das ist unser taxi hallo danke
auf geht's deiner tour
wie lange bist du schon taxifahrer
zwar sei jetzt 1900
602 regierungssitz markt hast du die
ganzen alten politiker in der sitzung in
bonn war also dann haben wir wirklich
hin und her gefahren aber nach dem umzug
im bund gibt es nicht
aber die gebäude sind noch da und alles
machen kann kann man der partys machen
so jetzt genau spüren das auf die letzte
seite arabische wirtschaft das ist ganz
schlimmer fall in bonn
was will alles und keine kümmerte
schnallen was ich mich frage warum
berlin ich von anfang an hauptstadt
geborgen
also damals war dass die beliebten 2
gefallen da ging das sichtbares wir
haben vorübergehend von gewalt walter
der kampf von der gartner in der nähe
gewohnt hat das ist die karten jetzt das
juni dass der hofgarten ist ziemlich gut
und da waren die berüchtigten
demonstration
hier war das genau
hunderttausend leute die leute die
gegenregierung waren
jetzt gehts zur deutschen welle
also wir sind hier geht's am rhein ein
bisschen größer als diese
wir sind angekommen sami ich danke dir
vielmals dass du uns hier rumgefahren
sehr gerne sehr informativ wir schauen
uns jetzt nochmal sehr gerne da wünsche
ich alles gute
dagegen könnte